Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the book of purification from
in the chapters regarding
yesterday we discussed the way that a
person goes about making we discussed
the parameter ters of aum. We discussed
what constitutes a
and in typical fashion once we learn how
to build something up we also learn what
compromises it right and so the next
chapter
and really the final chapter in this
subject and this topic is what
compromises
the things that invalidate.
The author says,
[Silence]
He says what
invalidates
or what compromises
is the same exact thing that compromises
wuboo. No difference.
That which compromises or invalidates
is the same thing that invalidates woo.
But there is an additional one
additional caveat and that is that a
person
is able to source water or that a
person is able to use it because
remember aum is for a person who doesn't
have water or is unable to use water for
whatever reason.
So here we have the things that break a
person's woo are the things that break a
person's
same thing
and one additional and that is that a
person now is able to use water
they either are able to source it or
they're able to use it now is invalid
immediately
immediately. And this is a a principle
that's even become a kind of idiom
or a kind of proverb used as an
analogy by the Muslim and especially
in Arab culture. They say
that that if if water becomes available
is invalid, right?
that's easy enough.
We now have the evidences for this.
If you suffer forch.
[Silence]
He tells us that two men during the
prophet's time sam
went on a journey. Now this is a weird
way of saying this. If it was only two
men that were on this journey, how does
he know about this? Well, Abu Sah knows
about this either because they told him
or because he is one of the two men. And
most likely it is he that's one of the
two men. But he doesn't want to say it
in a particular way because we'll see at
the end of the narration why he uses
this particular
model of of of of narrating. He
says, "So the time for salah came upon
them and they didn't have any water and
so they both made and they both made
their salah after which they were able
to source water. Water then became
available while the time for the salah
was still in. And so one of the two men
made wudoo and then remade his salah
that they had just made with and the
other did not.
And so when they returned they asked the
messenger of Allah sallallah.aii
wasallam and they mentioned to him what
had occurred. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii Wasam said to the one who
did not pray again. He said, "You have
done the sunnah. You were correct,
right? And your salah is correct." And
he said to the one who made wudoo and
made salah again, he said, "You will
receive your reward twofold, twice
fold." Why? Because he was unsure. And
he did what is safest because he was
unsure,
right? He did what would be safest for
his dean and for his salah. He didn't
know, but he was unsure. So he did what
he could to safeguard his prayer as best
as he knew how. And so for him, he
receives his reward twice. once for the
salah and once again for his you know
for his diligence and so forth. But
now if they were to go into that
situation again, would it be correct for
him to make his salah again? No. Not
only would it be incorrect, it would be
impermissible.
Why? Because now he knows.
So a person is not to understand from
this that it's best to do it twice. No,
we know now. This is in the case of not
knowing. So why do you think Abu said
two men went on a journey and so forth?
What do you think?
The other person. Do you think he was
one of them?
[Arabic recitation]
the one that was correct. So he doesn't
want to narrate it I was right, he
was wrong. So actually, you know, I was
correct. But anyways, that's what
happened. He didn't want the narration
to be that. So he narrates it in
the third person. And this is common
amongst the companions,
right? It's subtle. It's subtle, but it
it speaks volumes to their character.
I don't want to even be misunderstood
as praising myself. Not even
misunderstood
as saying something praiseworthy about
myself. I don't even want the listener
to,
you know, unintentionally
praise me in that sense. The companions
have this often. This is recurring in
the narrations that the companions
narrate.
You got two types of people.
You got one type that is concerned with
admiration of the listener.
from a guy that's been around the block
a few times, a guy that's been dealing
with people for a long time, been in
this for a long time. If you want to
know which kind of person that is, the
ones that testify and proclaim that they
don't care the most are the ones that
care the most.
The ones that say, "I don't care what
people think." That's the one that cares
the most what people think. People
usually
deny the things about themselves that
they hate the most about themselves or
the things that they wish they could
change about themselves.
The companions didn't do this. They
didn't even you know dispraise
themselves. As a matter of fact, in the
books of etiquets and seeking knowledge,
the scholars mention a type of person,
the the
mention that one of the slipperiest type
of people that praise themselves are the
ones that praise themselves by putting
themselves down. Oh, I'm just a humble
servant. I'm the I'm the least of you
guys. You're all better than me. I'm I'm
the worst.
Right? Cuz the inferred
idea is, you know, look how humble this
guy is. The companions never did that.
You'd never see them stand up and make
proclamations about themsel in the good
or in the bad unless they absolutely had
to in order to teach.
Right.
Dispraising oneself so that the listener
will infer praise is a type of praising
oneself and it's actually arguably worse
than outright praising oneself.
What does Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala say?
Says do not praise yourselves. Allah
knows best. Who is a person of tawa?
Allah knows best.
Well, what is this person supposed to
do? Not make themselves the main topic.
And that's hard. It's not easy. You have
to learn to do that because when a
person praises himself, he sees for
himself an opportunity. He is worried
what others think. And we all are
worried about what others think about
us. It's it's not correct and it's
improbable. It's
illogical for a person to not care what
other people think. This is ridiculous.
Of course you care what other people
think. I care what other people think
about me. Of course you do. That's where
most of your livelihood comes from. If
people think bad of you, this is going
to seriously harm you.
If people think good of you, this will
benefit you in ways. Nobody wants to be
dispraised.
And however, there are those who
do nothing in the way of praising
themselves. They leave that to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And then there are those who seek this
in subtle ways from others. And this is
a type of disease
right
inf
the two men
that you know one man has the gardens
in the middle of he has the gardens and
you know he is
the disbeliever in this story and
then he has the neighbor that is a
believer. Look at the way that he
structures his sentences.
He always structures his sentences with
Anna.
Me
I me I.
This is not the way of the companions of
the way of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. We can learn a lot from this
this subtle thing that Abu say here does
and that is that simply because he was
correct. He didn't want to be praised
for that in any way. And so he says two
men they went and this is what happened.
And right why the listener now learns
the lesson without focusing on on the
praise of Abu or anyone else.
Right. the first man to ever shoot an
arrow.
Does anyone know who it was?
Yes.
Abuas, the first man to ever shoot an
arrow. He shot the first arrow
in the history of this jihad. The
first arrow. Could you imagine the
honor? He shot the first arrow.
And he said we would go out with the
prophet sallall.aii
to battle.
[Silence]
He said we would go out to travel to go
to war and we would be so hungry that
we'd have nothing to eat to the point
that we would resort to eating desert
trees. tree leaves until our lips
blistered from ma malnourishment.
And we would go to relieve ourselves and
our stool would be so dry it would be
the stool of a goat or a sheep. You
ever see a goat or a sheep? Stools like
little balls, right?
And then after he said this, he thought
for a minute
and then
he stopped talking and he was very
disappointed in himself that he said
this.
He's already going to Jenna,
right? He's already going to Jenna. But
then when he thought about it, he was
excited to talk about the times he had
with the prophet Sam.
But then he thought better of it and he
wouldn't say it anymore. Wouldn't tell
this story anymore after that.
This is something that a person has to
fight to change about himself. Every one
of us cares what other people think
about us. However, how do we garner
praise? We garner Allah's pleasure. And
he is the one that places our love in
people's hearts without us even trying.
And if we seek praise from people subtly
or otherwise, very likely that it will
be at the expense of Allah's pleasure.
for
[Silence]
you. The bed.